hello every month another Sunday another
lecture for those tuning in the other
day we were discussing whether criteria
are objective okay we were trying out
the technical aspects here and I was
saying that the other day we looked at
you know definitions with officially the
definition of rational and the question
popped up whether these definitions are
objective and it's important very
important very pertinent because we call
it rational science and we don't need
the word rational in there it's implied
so we can just say science science
should be rational but then the question
is whether there are objective criteria
for rationale for defining rationality
and the issue came up that maybe there
isn't there's a different angle here and
it was mentioned by a fellow named Joel
read or ride read or ride the other day
and he says the following is so he says
the following he says your understanding
of how religion works because I
separated religion from science right
works is flawed and if it is not flawed
then it does not apply to several
religions a person comes up with a
rational idea that's what he says right
it is tested against available evidence
in this case he puts the example of
Scripture compared with proven facts you
can see his language while the source
material is not the same
referring to science versus religion it
is still highly a highly rational
process so he believes it's a rational
process because we have evidence where
proof were comparing against facts and
we're testing it you know in some way
which is more or less what he says
science does okay and then he added
another note here he says anything you
learn about theology you will just alter
the definition of rational and
irrational to fit your worldview okay
and he had a contradiction he says
actually I'm happy with your definitions
but you seem to misunderstand how
theology works and yeah we have here a
little contrast and what's the contrast
the contrast is between religion and
science is religion rational and as
you've seen in my chart you know there
is a difference between religion and
science I'm saying that religion has to
do a belief an opinion on one hand and
then on the other it only contains
irrational and supernatural theories
where a science does not but then the
question is can we define rational in an
objective way and then the issue came
you know is is there anything objective
at all because if there isn't I think
I've got a hang hang my gloves in a way
you know because if we can't define
rationality in an objective way then
we're wasting our time I think so
because you know what do we mean by
rational then is that subjective we
don't need the word as the point well I
think we do because I'm saying we do
need the word because we're separating
religion saying that that's irrational
theories fall under that branch and
rational theories fall under science so
we have to distinguish between well what
did you mean by rational what did you
mean by irrational is that subjective am
I going to reject your theory as
irrational simply because I don't like
it because I have
opinion about it is what's the criterion
isn't that how it kind of works if
someone comes to you and says question
how does magnetism work like a little
kid let's say that's the best example
okay because they don't know any of all
these arguments and whatever these come
with a simple simple question why is the
sky blue boys this guy need to know if
the explanation you give them is
rational by your standards or someone
else's standards whether it's rational
by anyone's standards or not they're
getting either take it or not they're
either gonna get that click that says I
kind of don't like what you're saying or
they're not yeah maybe they just can
accept it or they're not yeah and and
and you're right about in a ways besides
the point what anyone else thinks if
it's rational or irrational the kid is
gonna take it or leave it it's up to him
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true
that's when you explain something like
to a little kid or to someone who who is
not very particularly he's okay I'm just
gonna listen to your theory and I'm
gonna decided in my own goes home and
thinks about it that's fine that's
different than when you have a debate
and well the debate people have a clash
of ideas you have a against Z or pagans
B or whatever letter you want to use yes
against no on against off or whatever
opposites or at least differences maybe
not complete opposites but maybe there
are nuances there are differences and
and now we're not talking about a guy
just listening and going home which is
okay that scenarios it's pretty valid
but now we're having a clash of ideas
and we have to come up with the
synthesis and the question is whether we
can leave the conference room and say
well let's agree to disagree and I'm
saying that's not valid in science
that's validating religion not in
science you can't agree to disagree in
science that's what I'm saying that's my
point of view and how do I arrive that
you know why am I so so so vehement you
know why am i so insistent on this you
know am i just hard-headed that maybe
that's all there is
so I wrote a little piece and I put a
little and and again I'm not addressing
what the scenario he just mentioned
about the kid going home saying okay
I'll think about your theory etc I'm
talking about clash of ideas you know
you have quondam and at least now you
have the rope model and the question is
can they both be right and the answer is
absolutely not
maybe they're both wrong and maybe one
of them is right but both of them cannot
be right if they're contradictory right
and they are contradictory because one
assumes that we have discrete particles
the other one says all atoms are
interconnected so there is an obvious
difference there like and that creates
also you know I've seen the most popular
format of debate which usually goes
something like you have an audience and
you have two people 2,000 years though
votes on what they already say and how
many how many people do you think change
their mind do they have a number for
that like represent ten percent one but
be nice to know that number like because
that that's a microcosm of reality it's
usually not that many percent maybe so
it's never like one guy takes the cake
I think it happened once or so but the
guy who did the guy debating it was just
like completely racist completely like
he was just turning it off so people
just voted against him it's for the
audience in the sense it's like the two
people took they're debating by default
they're not gonna agree they're not
gonna see eye to eye so they're kind of
not doing it for each other they're not
trying to convince each other obviously
right so they're really just
for everyone else and that's different
than if a kid comes up to you just ask a
question yeah okay so I wrote a piece
and an article the other day and I want
to go over that real quickly because I
think it pinpoints what I mean by
objective we put this word up there and
we need that word I'm saying we can't
live without it and and the analogy goes
like this there's two boxers and they're
in the ring we'll call one the champ and
yellow one the contender okay so the
champ beats the tar out of the contender
contenders lying on the floor you know
he's got half and I'm pouring out of his
socket he's got all his teeth scattered
throughout the ring and he's on the
floor right and the temp looks down on
him and says I'm the champ I won this
fight I'm the winner
and the other guys knowing or not I'm
the champ I won this fight so who
objective need one to fight and let's
take it one step further let's go to the
like I said if we go to the Coliseum
Roman Colosseum and you know and a
Caesar you know puts his finger down and
so now you got to kill that guy so you
kill him they drag this guy out with his
feet first who's the winner now I mean
is he the champ the guy who just left
there's an objective champ I would
disagree said okay there's an objective
guess what you're talking about because
there's a difference take a game which
is very simple yes that's much more
simpler than the simpler than boxing in
a way okay because it could be a pie the
chess the whole part of the game the
winning has has been defined you win one
ex-wife
I mean I guess it's the same with boxing
but boxing what's wrong with boxing with
them too a little bit tricky because I
mean one guy is dead and the other ones
alive I guess the guy who's alive is the
winner but a problem with the word win
because that works with games and sports
but it doesn't work in life okay because
waiting for like the reason why they're
doing anything because someone might
someone might go into the boxing ring
and gain a million bucks for throwing
the fight so that was his win in life
but objectively in the game of boxing
okay but that's why there's a difference
between games where the win is
specifically defined what X Y Z
requirements are met you are declared
the winner okay it doesn't matter who
says it okay so if you need those
conditions if you meet those conditions
you are the winner in monopoly for
example you are the only one with money
by definition you are the winner but
that's different than then the
subjective kind of winning or is
throwing well you don't know you know my
weight is different than your win in
that sense you know I could go into the
fight and and get the crap beat out of
me like Rocky one yeah the movie rocky
gets the crap beat out of him he gets a
tie against the champ and he's he's
ecstatic yeah that he made it up there
in life he's a winner in that sense for
it to himself he's a winner that's yes
but in the game is just but again that's
subjective the fact that the person
believes that he died yeah that he won
or that he threw the fight all that
stuff is super hold on I'm just trying
to make the distinction between two
types of winning yeah yeah yeah there's
the subjective winning in the objective
we can call it that and I'm referring to
the objective part which is you know it
was your mind winning yeah if the guy
remains standing by definition he's the
winner you know the the guy crosses the
line first
you know in the race or whatever the
horse whatever that's the winner I think
yeah in the game
because in the game you're the winner
yeah and that's what I'm providing
himself could think it on the winner
because I even stood I even try right
and that's the subjective part that's my
point my point is that objectively in
the game the guy who wins is the guy who
to remain or the Boxee you know that's
the guy who remain standing the other
guy can go to the hospital or to the
cemetery and continue saying that he's
the winner for all we know that he won a
moral victory or whatever right and I'm
saying the moral win is subjective that
is subjective because you know you may
say you know I lost the battle but I
wonder war you can say many things of
that nature and a lot of that is
subjective in fact I'd say all of that
is subjective objectively is you know
the guy who remains standing and and
that's what I'm trying to get to here
I'm saying that if we have a clash of
ideas in other words let me give you an
example specific example which I gave
I'm saying you know we absolutely need
we absolutely need to define the word
object in physics the word thing what is
a thing and the reason for this is that
we can't do physics without things we
can't do things physics without objects
you absolutely need objects to do
physics and this is very easy we erase
all the objects in the universe
including yourself we'll just leave your
mind there to analyze what is there
happening if there's no there are no out
just nothing moving or better said how
can you explain magnetism if you don't
have anything that's more subtle and
that's more subtle obviously but yeah
same thing blank screen yeah but see the
the issues a lot of people will question
and that's my point here a lot of people
will question and it's unbelievable but
they do question these things that
whether you need a thing between two
magnets
and no question that if for them it's
not naturist not you know automatically
that there has to be some invisible
something in there then it's it's not so
automatic for a lot of people and that's
scary because again in physics we can't
do physics
we can't do physics without object you
need some kind of mediator to to mediate
between track transaction especially
invisible transactions like magnetism
gravity and so on you know we're dancing
around the issue but I think the
question that gets the heart of this is
we could have gotten - last week - or
what are the wind conditions in a debate
okay and that's why that's why I'm
giving this example as an introduction
to that question because that is the
question the question yeah the question
is you know can we talk about winning a
debate okay more or less that's where
we're getting to right so you know and
what I'm saying is can we declare an
objective objectively can we clear a
winner that's can we trade it like a
game yeah I like the boxing match but
it's it's just one it's just one more
game one more sport whatever right and
so I'm saying you know can we treat her
like a boxing match which is I think a
good analogy for this where there's an
objective winner
the guy who remains tank can we do that
with ideas right here we have a clash of
ideas can we do that with ideas that's
the issue yeah yeah and so this this
what I'm trying to get to I'm saying
look we need to define the word object
in physics and you know you a lot of
people might debate that for a hundred
years but you know you can't do physics
without an object you need to have an
object and once we cover that base and I
think that's the long discussion with
religious folk fine rational folk know
that we need some kind of object to do
physics and that's the starting point
what I call the golden principle okay so
we start there what does that mean it
means we have to define the word object
in the for the purposes of physics and
it turns out as you all know my argument
in the last 10,000 years no one has
defined or found the importance
discovered the importance of the word
object and the proof is that you can go
to any textbook of physics any
kindergarten high school college you
will never find a textbook that begins
by saying
this is an object this is what we mean
by object this is the definition of the
word odd you'll never find that the job
strange energy yeah the the acceleration
in our ass and you know they jump like
if you knew all this stuff already like
you know you know we don't need to do
you find out yeah we do
because it turns out that there are
several definitions for seven criteria
for the word object and I'm just going
to put a few of them up that I've
encountered over the years there could
be some more you know but I put six of
them there what is an object and some
people say that it's that which we can
see or touch and you'll find that
definition as the most popular in the
dictionaries other people have argued
that it's that which has mass others say
that that's it's that which has volume
others say well it's that which can move
and I propose that it's that with it
which has shape and these are all these
are criteria they're single criteria
well I separate and remember that the
first to see untouched they're usually
put together correct but what I'm saying
am yeah they have all kinds of
combinations and what I'm saying we
can't use the first five we can't use
see touch mass volume and move or motion
we can't use those in physics those are
not rational definitions for the word
object that we in by Rash I mean that
you can use it consistently I'm saying
you must have shape and so what happens
here okay so the guy said well that's
your opinion because that's that just
props up your religion you know what you
the theory that you're trying to push
forward and so he accuses you being
subjective he's saying well yeah your
definition of shape you know I see why
why you want it it only helps your case
it's like you know the the prosecutor
against the defender in in a trial and
the guy says well the victim died in
this way with a knife yeah oh that's
because you have a theory that my that
you found the the fingerprints of my
client on the knife but I'm saying it
was the glass because I found the
fingerprints of his wife I'm glad they
have things like that were you probably
murder
when you have to say alleged murder
right I guess I'm really careful with
the language who controls the language
kind of controls what language is
important he goes down it's kind of
governs how everyone knows the jury will
react if you always keep calling it the
murder weapon it's like it's implied
that this is the weapon on the Oh
equality that's why the defense usually
objection says alleged you know at least
now going to the defense the judge many
times he's a he's aware of these little
tricks and so he says overrule you know
that the prosecutor who says objection
to what the defender says or vice versa
the judge will say overruled or or
continued you know he he will grant it
but he's aware of these little tricks
that die the lawyers play an important -
that is none of the jurors really know
they mostly they're not aware of it
they're not aware of what rules like
always you're taking for that or
whatever because these people tourney
should disregard that stand and it also
goes to the yeah and it also goes to the
issue of language being very important
especially when you're debates how you
handle the language how you manipulate
or move these words around how you use
them it's very important very crucial a
lot of debates are really about one word
yeah and I mean that's probably the most
common one where they're trying to
debate some line in the Quran or some
line in the Bible and they're both and
they're really just the line rolling
around they're saying a color words
string of words and they're both trying
to interpret it their way or the other
yes way yeah because depending on how
you interpret it favors your religion
and so the the question comes up is you
our way to determine these things in
other words which of these definitions
should I apply and if the guy says well
you want shape because it favors your
argument and I prefer see or touch the
other guy says Matthew the guy says
volume or that which moves and how do we
decide how do we objectively decide
which one to have well that's where you
go into a debate that's where you have
to put on the gloves and find out who
the champ is one person one kid okay and
the other one yeah there's two you're
right because if you're deciding one kid
that really doesn't matter doesn't
matter words it's like a kid understands
you well in a debate if you're using the
same words then you can have to come to
a consensus of what these words mean
either you're both gonna be using but
how do you thank you
I know H I know but how do you come to a
consensus to both use let's say we're
both gonna be talking about
I don't know how armadillos became the
way they are and we both have a
disagreement on the word life okay but
now before we even start the debate or
usually it'll devolve to this anyway
yeah some worry that's gonna be pivotal
isn't it more important to talk about
the notions that we mean instead of
really fretting on the instead of both
using agreeing to use the word life you
use a and I use B okay for your notion
and not in my notion isn't that isn't
that a cleaner way to do debate where so
you have one notion for life the word
life and I have another notion for life
you say oxygen and eat I say has sakes
and and eat so can't we just like put
agreed to disagree
no not agree to disagree use two
different words you actually we don't
use the word life anymore
you use the word a and I use the word
well but yeah but what is it what is the
problem I see with that I see with that
more or less again it just all I'm
hearing is
agree to disagree that's what I hear
there that's what I understand by that
the other thing I understand by that is
what the mathematicians has spread out
there that everything is relative by
that meaning well you have your opinion
I have my opinion we're back to opinion
we're back to subjectivity we're back to
Oh science is subjective it depends on
what you want to believe so we're back
to religion and that's what the problem
comes in we have to have a champ
standing alive on the ring and the other
one spread out on the floor there was no
other way there's got to be a battle to
the death but the original question was
does that mentality a battle to the
death
apply can we apply that to a debate or
science yeah and that's my point is I'm
saying I'm saying not only we can but we
should and we must why okay because
because we can't have two ideas remain
standing that are contradictory we can't
have like quantum mechanics and a rope
model for example someone someone we
could both be wrong but for sure we
can't both be right so someone maybe the
Rope has to do with how mother nature
runs her shop fine maybe it doesn't but
for sure both of them cannot be the way
mother nature runs her shop she can't
run in with all the particles in the
universe interconnected or at the same
time and at the same time all the
particles being discrete someone is
wrong but then the question arises what
is the purpose of a debate okay isn't it
just to convince it's for what either
it's for the champ to remain standing
that's the purpose how do you determine
what are they that's the definitions and
that's why I'm saying you know we have
to have a criteria for example for the
word object and we must have that word
so we got a fight there's no way you got
to have that confrontation you can't say
well okay you continue with yours and
I'll continue with my we can't have that
because if what the guy if his
definition his criteria is irrational he
can't use it consistently and we can
show that okay we can show an example or
or whatever or a reasoning of what he
can't use it consistent we give him you
know some kind of analogy or whatever
that you know then at that point that
guy has to either put an example showing
that you know he can use it or or
counter your example or some he's got a
fight he's got a fight fight fight
there's no way he can say well I didn't
like your example because it destroys my
little religious so I'll continue
believing in mine
no well then he then he is the guy who
is subjective not you we kind of
understand this kind of hypocritical
well it's kind of like like unspoken
rule in debates which is kind of goes to
what you're saying with using the word
consistently it's kind of like if you
say one thing one time and then later on
in the debate say something else then
it's like okay now so I think shaky view
he's not on solid ground and that kind
of goes to what you're saying where if I
use the word life or God to say like
specifically this is what I mean by god
and I use it in this sentence and then
later on I mean I mean in different ways
like okay god is an anthropomorphic
being here he makes the universe then
over here intelligence
he's a concept got turned into a console
now I mean that was kind of more vague
because the whole I mean God I guess is
just a more big discussion but like life
for example if you use life for only
things that breathe right and then start
talking about a Novation system they now
say okay is that life or not we like
anyone in the audience this this is
listening right would go wait what about
anaerobic right and then he kind of we
we have this implied contradiction or
hypocrisy yeah and and I'm saying that
the guy who insists despite that you
show that and just said well I'm not
gonna fight anymore he leaves the ring
he lost he by lost I mean that he's the
guy who's being subjective then because
he's going to insist on his definition
no matter what even though you showed or
you presented a case where his
definition is irrational inconsistent
unscientific and he insists on it
because he just wants to preserve his
religion then he's the guy who is
subjective not the
guy not at least up to that point not
the guy who is the champ the guy who
remain standing it's interesting because
in debates they have rules against how
to conduct yourself like you can't walk
up and punch the other unit for example
right that's not allowed that's not
allowed usually usually then what kind
of champ is he I'm gonna boil but they
don't have rules for the content of your
speech which is interesting they don't
have what because that's what you're
essentially proposing or supposing to
have rules where you can't just say
whatever you want right you kind of have
to not make sense that some people might
not make sense of what you're saying
still but it's not about making sense or
not it's about contradicting let's take
that rule before we go into any other
one you know the irrational did you
can't contradict yourself that's right
or one rule that we can kind of agree on
in a debate which isn't which is it
pretending to the how you conduct
yourself with more to the contents of
what you're saying if you use you know
dog here and then cut there when you
mean you know yeah you can't use the
word dog dog in a cat it starts getting
like oh like we should have a yellow
card - yellow card you're out but it's
interesting the right doesn't the ref
have to understand what you're saying
to catch the contradiction well the way
it works usually I mean in real life is
that the other guy you know if you have
a prosecutor against the defender or you
know then they clash their ideas because
they have a different interests and
let's just say that in science those
interests have to do with you know what
you believe in or what you with the
theories you're presenting and so
there's going to be a clash of theories
there's gonna be a clash of explanation
this guy has this explanation the other
guy has that one and there's gonna be a
classroom if they don't agree in this
guy is you know they're gonna fight to
the death for their own ideas and and
and the purpose of these debates and
again we're not doing about you
explaining to a little kid we just goes
away
we're talking about fight we're talking
about a clash we're
where this guy says oh no you're wrong
and I'm right and the other guy says the
opposite and you know they're they're
fighting and so the issue here is you
know ideas will clash and at that point
it's the other guy who has to be smart
enough to say let me tell you what's
wrong or what's irrational really
irrational about your theory about your
explanation he goes in there he gives
examples where he just reasons it out or
whatever he shows that there's a failure
in logic whatever he might do and the
other guy has that's the boxing man yeah
the other guy has to do the same thing
to yours that's usually how it works
it's a give-and-take like first let me
tell you you answer it the other
person's question about your theory and
then you follow it up with a question
about theirs and then it's their turn
they answer the your question then have
a question about yours right goes back
and forth like that answer their
question usually works a little more
violent than that but I mean the usual
structure I mean after the intro where
they kind of talk for 10 minutes about
their theory and then 10 minutes about
your theory so we have a basis that's
usually our debate starts yeah just
gonna have the floor for 10 minutes what
are you saying about it in this guy's
the 10 then they go into the back and
forth which is basically criticizing
each other yeah which is an answer
question answer question or criticizing
the other guy that's what I made my
question yeah he goes I answer your
question and then I have a question for
you right and you answer my question for
me and I think that's how it should work
in that sense you know that is a
free-for-all that's a boxing match right
there and I'm saying on yeah the the
rule of contradiction where you say oh
not contradiction but yeah consistency
yeah isn't that more a question of logic
rather than rationality well it is a
question of logic but then what do we
call that whole phenomenon we call it
rational is he being ranch's he being by
ration I mean that you can use something
consistently and buy a rash and I also
mean that it's scientific because you
can continue with your idea and be
inconsistent and say well I'll continue
with my thought because I don't care
what you
opinion you have about I'm gonna
continue with it even though you showed
me that it's irrational no you can't
have not in science you you can do that
in religion but not in science that's
what I'm saying okay who solved the
question of how what is the purpose of a
debate / how do you declare someone the
winner is it a question of votes well
it's not then that's what I'm saying the
audience you know could be completely
ignorant we could have flat earthers in
every seat and it won't make a
difference so it's this is not a
question of voting or anything like that
again it's got to do only with reasoning
one guy reason there's only two guys on
the island that's it there's no the fish
are the only spectators and I wouldn't
call that a debate because I have the
three different words which are argue
discussion and debate debate I mean it
goes basically debate is you and me for
an audience discussion is you and me
kind of what you're saying we're we're
just trying to get to the bottom of
who's right or what's right an argument
is just you know for ego I'm sorry
there is no audience in science it's
just two guys in an island that's
science science is just look at the
reasoning at the ideas not you know even
if you're a spectator you gotta think of
it as you know these guys weren't
talking for you they're just this
debating among themselves and you come
in there you listen you say okay what am
I gonna judge this for myself you know
it's not like they did it for me so yeah
you can call it a discussion a fight and
there's only you guys doesn't go back to
the explaining something to a kid
because if you're just explaining to
something to a kid then you are the two
people right and assuming the kid has
some disagreement with your explanation
yes then he goes into the other then we
have a discussion correct then he goes
into the discussion but if he just walks
away and says okay I'm all over it then
that's different but if if he comes in
there and stands his ground and says
well you know I don't believe in what
you said I didn't agree and he might
even show what's wrong with your
reasoning or whatever fine then we got a
debate didn't debate discussion
because let's talk about the
scientifically okay bait from now on is
when there's an audience discussion is
just you and me basically yeah so so
forget the debate we're not gonna talk
about debates anymore kill that's that's
religion yeah straight up yeah
and that's what mantha meadow this guy's
look for votes it's just you and me
little Timmy your pops your Timmy I come
to you with a question
I thought your name was a bird how do
you magnets work and you answer it with
your typical gibberish and then I would
say I'm a little Timmy and I have a
question I guess I guess it doesn't
happen it doesn't have to be that little
Timmy has a counter-argument in the
sense that I don't have something to
replace what you're saying I might still
not know what Magnus how they work but
something about what you say is fishy or
incomplete so I'm still left unsatisfied
so I ask are you sure about this part
because that doesn't sound right
that would constitute discussion that
would constitute all the rules and
sounds in fact I covered that step as
well there's there's three possibilities
and and the way it works is that the guy
who who walks out of the ring and says
I'm not gonna have a discussion because
I don't want to have one I'm I'm not
interested I'm not gonna try to find the
definition for the word object I don't
care about it okay fine he walks out of
the ring he's not the champ he can't go
out there and say oh I'm the champ no he
can't
in other words he can't say that he
rationalized something he can believe in
what it wants he's you can do all his
religion that he wants but if he wants
to really do science he's got a fight
there's got to be a fight there's got to
be a clash of ideas discussion yes
Anse pointed out now there's the other
guy who says okay that guy steps into
the ring he says okay I'm gonna for the
word object he says I'm gonna propose
motion okay so you show that you know
for example that you have to have an
object before you can have motion we can
go through all these reasonings anyways
the point is you show that his reasoning
is incorrect or irrational because he's
got things backwards or whatever and the
guy can insist and say well I'm gonna
insist that this is the way it is well
then he's got a subjective opinion
that's all he's got because he wasn't
able to counter your example or your
criticism of his definition and maybe
he's not even able to throw yours down
the drain either so so then what's his
point he's just got a religion he's just
got an opinion that's it
and he's going to insist on that because
it preserves his religion and then
there's the third guy and that's the guy
who steps into the ring and says I don't
have to tell you what I think I'm not
gonna tell you my theory I'm gonna
destroy yours all by itself
that would be me and that's it and
that's not allowed in science either
that's rejected in science in science
you have to fight and fight means that
you got to put on the gloves that means
you've got to show your cards and the
reason is is the following that you
can't really go up there and and hide
your idea the reason you're up there and
the reason you're you're fighting
against the other guy is that for sure
you got a different way of thinking that
the other than the other guy and we need
to see that you know the the whoever
whoever or what's then now analyze that
you know later on again these guys are
not doing it for an audience but if you
want to say okay I want to see what's
out there in science this guy has this
theory and this guy has this other
theory then you can compare them and say
well I prefer this theory I'm gonna
adopt this as mine or whatever and now I
have an explanation for how magnet works
or whatever but if you don't see the
other guy's idea if the other guy just
says look I'm just gonna destroy your
theory well we got a problem let me tell
you
problem is that for example the word
object we need to have a definition of
the word object and if you happen to
beat the champ if you happen to destroy
his definition say look I destroyed your
definition all by itself without showing
my cards then we can't do physics
because we still don't have a definition
we have nothing to work with
that means you have to provide your
version because maybe a person but your
version is more irrational than the
other guys and maybe that's why you're
hiding it maybe you're afraid of people
ridiculing you or whatever the issue is
that we need to come out with a
definition of the word object we can't
leave the ring we can't leave the
conference room until we have a
definition so it's not sufficient for
you to go in there and say look I
destroyed your definition fine you
destroyed it and what do we have now we
can't do physics so yes you do have to
provide an alternative and that's why
you're in the ring in the first place
because obviously if you're gonna
criticize the other guy's definition you
have something else hidden in your mind
you have some some gripe with it so yeah
you have some addendum you want to do
yeah you got something else please spell
it out in this and let's put all the
cards on the date and it goes back to
what is the purpose of a discussion or a
debate in this case where what does I'm
a champ mean does it mean we both
understood no it's nobody cares point of
science well okay if if wooden guy at
least uh because some of this is
unknowing you know maybe both guys are
wrong right or irrational but but let's
assume you know there is a definition
the or or theory and the other guy
challenges it and he can't show that the
Champs definition or explanation is
irrational whereas the champ can show
that the contenders definition or theory
is irrational you know at that point in
again through reasoning through through
examples through analogy through any
any part of this you show that the other
guy is not being consistent or in some
way as being irrational and that stands
on its own you know if I can show that
the word motion is not a good criteria
for the word object that object precedes
motion I can go through the whole
reasoning then you can't use the word
motion do you guys say well I'm gonna
continue with motion because I've got
this theory and it depends on that
definition well then we don't care we
don't care because the guy cannot defend
his definition and it stands all on its
own and that's more or less what I did
with the this word irrational okay and
one more time let me just point that out
and I'm not gonna go through all of
these but the first one converting
concepts into physical objects okay
period stop there basically create
criteria for losing an argument debate
or in other words I'm gonna propose what
I'm gonna propose here is a definition
of the word irrational but they don't
need what would essentially mean is
these are conditions for the lose yeah
yeah well I'm saying I'm saying here I'm
gonna define the word irrational these
are the criteria I'm gonna put which I
believe are objective and and the first
thing is that if you look at each one of
these things statements standing alone
they are objective I looked at them a
million times and there is nothing
opinionated about them the other issue
that comes in is whether the criteria to
begin with is objective or subjective
you know someone answer mentioned the
other day well you know I think that
anything that is rational is anything
that is read and you can come up with
anything right and the question is can
we accept that as a criteria for
rationality or for your rationality and
I'm saying the following I'm saying to
find you can add to this list and you
can subtract for it from this list
either way you get a you got to justify
what you add or what you subtract and
here I'm saying look if you convert a
concept into a physical object your
theory is irrational because now you're
going to be moving a concept and I think
that's a standalone thing now you can
try to criticize that specific statement
and say well
I don't agree with that and you got to
say okay why don't you agree with that
why isn't a theory in which you're
moving concepts why is it not irrational
so you so now the onus is on the
Challenger to show that that statement
is you know invalid for as a criteria
for defining irrationality that's what
I'm saying and and if he says look I
think that anything that rational is
read and we and we finally you know we
mall over and we find that yeah
everything that is rational has to be
read then we put is the fifth criteria
B's okay fifth criteria everything all
theory anything that is not read if
that's what we decide right if we can
fight we can't find any flaw to that
criterion then yes we have to accept
them put is number five but but what I'm
saying here I don't see any reason why
we have to reject number one if it's
patently clear that a theory in which
you moved concepts you know is
irrational and at the same time you know
if if you're gonna say that any theory
that is not read is also rational and we
can't find any flaw with that criterion
then we should add it not it doesn't
mean we got to subtract the other one it
means that now we have another criteria
that we add to the dis list that's what
I'm saying I think the issue that you're
kind of dancing around not seeing is
well you're talking about the irrational
theory about the definition of
irrational is you're really looking for
the criteria for a loss in an argument
discussion or debate
you're we're essentially treating it
like a game where we're trying to it's a
box we're trying to define but like luck
see no no no man go to baseball we're
trying to define the rule you should I
have to find what are the rules of
baseball that's what you're trying to do
right now with the revenue sends it
right track we're trying to figure out
how do we how do we know this guy won
debate argument discussion and this guy
lost or won the fight but but that's
what that's objectively better but my
question underlies all this is is that
the right way to talk about science is
is the champ analogy adequate for
science is that the person purpose of
science to have a guy standing at the
top raising his fist or is it more
subtle with this new understanding
because it's not so much that we're
playing a game of chess we are boss
boxing is more we're trying to both
understand the universe isn't that the
purpose of science yeah so on your
waiting how how does that how is that or
how does that contradict the boxing
match because the problem with all this
falls under the word understanding or
the notion of understanding as we know
it and if we're both trying to
understand the universe ok we could both
understand it with different with
conflicting theories that's the problem
yeah and again the theory has to be
challenged you can't you can believe not
see we're confusing understanding with
belief there yeah that's and that's
wrong that's what what science deals
with understanding religion deals with
belief but the tricky the trick in this
is the word understanding because that
really on underlying science it
underlies everything about science
because if explaining explaining if
explaining implies understanding mm-hmm
you can't explain something to someone
in a didn't lenguage they don't
understand and say you've explained it
because they don't know what you're
saying
well you explained it you can't vouch
for for all your audience yeah I mean if
someone doesn't understand well I can't
help them you know if again if you make
a movie of your mechanism it's obvious
you know every part is there for example
how to make a car you know and so you
say this is how you make a car this is
my theory how you make a car and if you
like this it'll work and someone can't
follow because they don't just don't
have the intelligence the vol you get a
I don't know downs patient no no I can't
vouch for that purse I'm gonna take it
more extreme okay again if I'm talking
to a Chinese person and he doesn't
understand English explain magnetism
would you say that I'm doing science
you're doing science it's science is
explaining not understanding
but I thought science I would actually
disagree it's the science is
understanding because when you're
explaining even to yourself that's what
you do most of the first before you get
explained not the you have to understand
that erst explaining is irrelevant
essentially we just want everyone on
earth to understand the way the world
works yeah I I don't care if someone's
throwing words at me if I don't
understand it
well then but again it science is about
explaining its I explained a mechanism
where I make a movie of them that's
where you shine where you can explain
how the magician did the magic trick
well yeah I didn't understand that his
problem not mine you're making a mistake
there because essentially you're saying
as long as I understand it I'm I'm okay
if I can make a movie it's not making a
movie you can find how do you find
that's what science is ending that's
that's what a movie is that's what a
theory is a movie understanding the the
focal point I'm not claiming I'm
explaining to you how to make I'm
explain to the world to whoever watches
the movie and if no one understands it
then then why wouldn't anybody
understand they're watching a movie well
they don't understand they have a
problem maybe I'm saying the focal point
of science is understanding not
explanation yeah because if no one
understands even yourself even if you
don't understand not saying I don't
notice that if I just throw some blame
on the screen okay and I say I'm
explaining you I don't even understand
and no one understands it that's not
science so it's understanding is the
focal point not explaining and
essentially explaining implies
understanding that's that would be Mario
human you can't say you've explained
something without anyone understanding
even yourself no but you can send you in
heaven explain you can't even make the
movie if you can't understand it that's
the point what that's my point in you
can make a movie that means you can
explain it because you made the movie
that's my boy yeah yeah yeah but but
people don't understand the movie that's
not my problem but because you
understand
someone has to understand what you're
saying if I can make the movie if I can
make a movie objectively with objects
physics right now talking about physics
if I can make a movie and show all the
objects how they work and how something
comes out of that something whatever
effect or gadget or whatever I'm trying
to explain there right I've explained it
because I've made the movie why would I
make the movie if I don't understand it
now if there's a part of it if there's a
part missing in there someone said what
you're missing something there and that
part I didn't understand and then you
either clarify it or say oh I didn't I
didn't see that that's fine but if you
make a movie showing you know like how
does a magnet attract another how does
gravity work if you're explaining it
it's because you made a movie then you
were able to explain it to yourself
understand it there's up the edges and
I've made a movie I don't care but it
was no point as understanding that's my
point
that is the win in science if you're
trying to get to the bottom of how
gravity works right I can't Bible not
understand oh no no forget it right now
you're trying to understand how gravity
works understand how gravity works not
explaining it not that's the wrong word
that's what I'm saying you're not trying
to show people how gravity works you're
not trying to show yourself how earth
you're not trying to to see gravity
you're trying to understand what does
understand mean if not an explanation no
understand yeah I've explained it myself
in order to understand it myself there's
a nuance between explain and understand
because explain yeah what is under it
again yeah I guarantee it puts focus on
hopefully oh yeah we start with
explanations yeah yeah but your
explanation could could make no sense
you're right in that sense yes not
science
you could have explanations that aren't
science but you can't have understanding
the isn't science understanding is
always science no I'm wrong no you can
understand the theory of God created
the UNAM I understand it I understand
the theory is that science does what
does understand me and that was my
original question that's what this we
need a definition for understanding
because that is the bedrock of science
no bedrock and science is explained you
need to be able to explain to other
people including to yourself here that
you're your own audience you need to be
able to explain a mechanism you have to
explain in other words you reason
something out and say well how would I
explain how magnet attracts another or
how old is Penn Foster the center of the
earth so you're a trying to explain that
you're trying to find some kind of
mechanism what do we do with mechanism
we first try to explain them to yourself
or whatever so that you understand that
you're your own audience so so you do
have to begin with trying to figure out
how it works and and maybe you still
don't understand and you say well how do
I explain this
well explaining is the wrong words the
explaining implies to someone else
understand I know you could be explained
to us understand you don't agree out
here so without anyone that's but that's
the wrong I think that's the wrong use
of the word okay then we're trying to
win I give me a word and is the right
word understand is what we're looking at
if you can't understand when no one has
explained if an Apple falls to the
ground don't have no one explained it to
you but you understand how gravity not
how it works but but what the effects of
gravity are you can at least understand
that if I thought about mechanisms we're
just we're just caring about
understanding right now I want to put
the focal point on science okay where it
doesn't matter how the information is
organized in your head it doesn't matter
because you can explain something you
didn't you could be just brainstorming
phrase okay yeah and you don't
understand it yet correct but you're
explained no you haven't yet you're
explained because that's a place
brainstorming is is explaining without
understanding using anything you're
throwing out only ideas but you have not
explained because you could have
different contradictory explanations
so all you did was list explanation but
you don't have an explanation still for
you might even win a you you might even
be defining concepts for all we know
yeah we have many explanations but
understanding is the one that is the
right one essentially no it's not
because I can understand how God created
the universe it's not science
I can explain how garden is explained
and made the universe and it wouldn't
make no sense to anyone yeah but that's
it was then why that's why I'm saying
that we need criteria for a rational
explanation but that's why the rational
is important because explain anybody can
explain rationally not everybody can
explain but that's why the word rational
is crucial to understanding yeah but
understand why his own understanding cuz
the candy comes up we got a bowl over
there anyways all I can tell you give
you my version of it and and that's all
I can do you know I'm saying that
science is about explaining not about
understanding that's my point of view
okay
and I'm saying that it's not only
explaining but it's got to be rational
and for that you need criteria and I'm
saying here we have objective criteria
understand anything we do have to think
about but I think everything that you're
trying to say goes to the point of you
know when you talk about rational
defining rational defining irrational
what you're doing or putting the rules
for winning a debate or or at least for
a discussion or discussion so that so
that we can because right now we don't
have rules essentially right now we're
not playing a sport
we're not playing chess we're just kind
of throwing words at each other and who
cares what we say correct it really
doesn't matter what we say at this point
because we don't least not we're not
treating it as a game as such where we
have a clear just winner
whatever create clear criteria for
winning for winning in the sense of who
remains standing
but then again going back to the
understand why I'm saying you need
criteria and those are the criteria I'm
putting under ration but then you and
you would definitely put science as a
sport science is a sport a habit how
nice a sport yeah I guess it's a game it
is a game in a way I mean what are we
trying to we're playing a game against
mother nature we're saying she hides her
secrets and so I'm gonna try to figure
out your secret isn't a game against
mother nature each other
well someone takes always the role of
mother nature because you know I'm right
and you're always wrong you know so you
know in that sense we're fighting
against the ghosts but we're saying you
know I can explain how mother need to
run sir shop you can understand we're
gonna have a kitchen fight tonight geez
Duke right the whole point is to see how
mother nature runs our shop how does the
universe what what are the unseen forces
what did the unseen forces look like
essentially exactly and because we
already know all the or have been able
to explain and understand the macro
world visible stuff we have no problem
in fact some business Invisibles that we
we can talk about air and we pretty much
got a good handle on what gases
invisible gases do so so we pretty much
that part has already been settled in
the 19th century
what they do is also just the effect
what they look different no what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is yeah here
we can explain we can not only describe
mathematically what air does what gases
do we we can describe them
mathematically and and qualitatively as
well and we can also explain things we
can predict also we can do all those
things all of it
you know we physicists don't deal with
those issues anymore because they were
settled in the 19th century essentially
most of what we have problems with are
the invisible entities or that mediate
you know the atom gravity magnetism
those we haven't figured out yet and the
mathematicians say well we're not gonna
deal with that any longer because mother
nature
it's really stumped us we have no way of
figuring that out and a lot of people
will say no but it's because they're not
aware that mathematics cannot explain
anything and these people say look we're
not even interested in explaining
anymore we call that philosophy we will
just describe and that's where we have
that's where we went off to the wrong
end because science is not about
describing science is about explaining
hold on or understand one one good last
question yes because since we're really
talking about rules for winning a debate
or discussion
Oshin rules for winning a discussion a
scientific discussion uh-huh the rules
are now extremely important now we do
have to argue about the rules or the
word irrational yeah it's assuming we
get treated as a sport right let's just
let's just jam we're gonna treat science
as a sport okay so now we need rules for
the sport okay now if we do a good
analysis if we do it like this now you
we do have to have a long talk about the
rules because that would because we've
essentially been playing this sport now
we just have to find out who's been
winning or or at some point you know
it's like in in in many sports like you
know in basketball it used to be two
pointers and one pointer right and then
they came up with a three pointer
something outside so they came with a
new definition for that game and it's
like you know developed in that
direction means here aren't we gonna
give the guy who shoots from outside the
you know the area I mean that guy's got
a it's not the same thing in the dogs
but that's got to have an extra point
because the guys shooting from way out
there so they changed the rules these
are the rules now right this is a little
bigger because we've been playing the
sport you're if we're gonna treat it
essentially what we're doing is we've
been playing this sport for 2,000 years
and now we're gonna come up with the
rules to see you won and that's a
problem because now depending on the
rules essentially the rules are
arbitrary because depending on what we
call the rules that's what one so it
kind of it's it's like it's like yeah
statement after the fact okay but then
it goes back down to votes because now
we have to
three on the rules no no no it doesn't
go to votes and again that's what I'm
saying it's not a question saying okay
let's go with the flat earthers and lead
let's read some consensus no no we do
not reach consensus with flat earthers
you either you either trash them and
send them out no that's why I'm saying
it's about reasoning and that's the
point
if mathematics is not the language of
physics you know it's not a rule of
rationality we can't include it in there
just to accommodate the mathematicians
and say well that's what they've been
doing for the last 400 years so how we
have to we have to include mathematics
at all costs know if mathematics hasn't
if if science is about explaining and
math cannot explain math is excluded
completely it's rejected it's out of the
out of out of you know and that's why we
have to determine if science physics /
physics is about explaining something
like two magnets yeah yeah but then and
for that we don't need any math we need
to find out what invisible entity
mediates that transaction but as far as
the rules go if we take a rules if we
take X rules right rules one the flat
earthers when they don't win the debate
if we take rules - yeah but so we have
to know that's what I'm saying we have
to do it through a rational debate we
have the box and the guy either defends
his position he can't leave the ring if
he leaves the ring he lost he his rule
doesn't count if he stays in the ring
and fights then he's got a he's got a
win and by winning I mean that he's and
again if if he wins
whatever he proposes if he does win it
doesn't mean you got to reject the other
rules it just means we have an addition
an additional rule that's what we're
saying
you know he's got to have a reason to
reject it with the rule that you're
proposing in this case for rationality
and proposing you know using concepts as
objects he's gonna have a reason to
reject that and if he says look you know
I think we got to include that anything
that is read fine if we
we finally decided that we can't find
anything wrong with this proposal all we
do is add it on and now we have more
rules but you know you have to have that
debate you have to have you have to
analyze each proposal until you get
those rules in there anyways we'll see
you tomorrow same time same station and
hopefully you'll all be here
we'll see you that bye bye